hop
[Musique]
un séminaire s'est déroulé durant trois
jours au jardin botanique de la réunion
et à la bibliothèque départementale et
enfin aux archives départementales
une formation organisé par le rectorat
de la réunion sur le thème du paysage
autour de l'archéologie du patrimoine et
de la géologie
et stagiaires on va dire plutôt qu'ils
sont formés aujourd'hui il ya des
enseignants du premier et du second
degré la plupart sont professeurs relais
en service éducatif donc dans des
structures culturelles dont 6 décès de
d'utiliser un petit peu tout ce qu'ils
vont découvrir aujourd'hui pour créer
des nouvelles ressources un peu plus
innovantes et kylie arts et sciences on
a également ya pas que des enseignants
en fait parce que le but d'un prêt accès
que ce soit aussi interministériel et
intercatégorielle donc en fait on m'a
aussi des médiateurs des agents dont il
ya des agents du parc il ya une
stagiaire du service archéologique
ladakh réunion on a des artistes qui
participent aussi en tant que donc non
pas formateur mais forme et donc deux
artistes de création en cours qui
viennent de métropole et qui a c'est ça
notre réac et en fait c'est vraiment
l'idée de croiser les publics parmi les
intervenants conférencier bernard
leveneur directeur du musée léon dierx
qui est intervenu sur l'histoire du
paysage dans la peinture et david
gagneur directeur de l'icône hawtai qui
a présenté les tables numériques avec
une exploitation sur le paysage
le musée va présenter une conférence sur
des paysages célèbre des paysages
oublier pour montrer en fait un peu dans
l'histoire de l'art comme en satin
paysage était très connue et ils sont
passés complètement à le totalement
oublié aujourd'hui
et pour montrer justement le regard
qu'on a pu apporter à un moment sur les
paysages célèbre de la réunion enfin est
aujourd'hui
présenté au public et ce public est
essentiellement un public d'enseignants
ou
de formateurs d'enseignants c'est
jacques après c'est aussi
finalement préparer la venue du public
aussi au musée c'est conforme les profs
pour que ces profs puissent ensuite
franck programmée des visites et que ces
visites c'est en fait à former éduquer
les jeunes de la réunion on va essayer
de leur apporter des éléments
iconographiques sur la lecture des
paysages sait comment se repérer dans la
base et une fois qu'on a identifié un
corpus de documents intéressants on peut
envisager ensuite une activité
pédagogique sur un outil culturel
manquer donc l'icône aux tâches qui est
une table tactile numérique
itinérante qui se déplace dans les
établissements scolaires une formation
qui associe un aspect scientifique sur
la lecture de paysage un aspect
artistique et patrimonial
[Musique]